the great Adrien monk for a while there
you were solving a major case every week
I couldn't have done it alone I could
have but it would have taken
longer I have traumatic symptoms
unprecedented in psychiatric
history he's afraid of heights it's his
second biggest fear after germs actually
it goes germs needles Birds then
Heights that was no accident he was
murdered you have to help me turn turn
it turn it turn it there's a bomb
there's a bomb you're not
helping we should leave a
note when Co hit I was in bad shape this
is
mine look at us everybody's you they're
going to hate it here's what happen so
how does that feel to be working again
like riding a
bicycle I'm glad to hear that I mean
it's
[Music]
terrifying